bonjour frédéric bricout merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous dans la
matinale de rtl france alors est ce qu
on quand on tousse au porte-monnaie ça
marche
oui ça fonctionne effectivement nous
avons donc mise en application cette
cette suppression des aides facultatives
de la commune aux familles d'enfants
délinquants et de une application de
cette nouvelle règle communal nous avons
constaté que certains perturbateurs
c'était ne faisait plus connaître avait
disparu du radar
expliquez-nous comment est-ce que vous
en êtes arrivés là vous dites avoir tout
essayé pour tenter d'enrayer ce problème
de délinquance dans votre commune
quelles ont été les étapes qui ont mené
à cela alors tout à fait nous avons tout
essayé donc nous avons nous sommes
inscrits dans le conseil local de
sécurité et de prévention de la
délinquance nous avons mis en place un
conseil des droits et devoirs des
familles dans peau dans lequel sont
convoqués les parents des enfants
perturbateurs ou où sont présents la
gendarmerie la sous préfecture le maire
les services sociaux le parquet et on
leur explique valérie schlée les
éléments qui leur sont reprochés donc
sans sanction c'est quelque chose de
c'est plutôt préventif on essaye de
demander aux personnes la petite voix la
jeune fille ce qu'il ne peut pas et de
trouver des solutions
nous avons mis en place un conseil des
droits et devoirs de la location c'est à
dire que nous convoquons les les voisins
qui sont des perturbateurs dans le
quartier pour les sommer de 2,2 laisser
tranquille l'eure l'eure leurs quartiers
leurs voisins nous avons augmenté nos
effectifs de police municipale de quatre
à six agents nous avons augmenté notre
notre réseau de vidéoprotection et puis
malgré tout nous alors qu'audrey est une
ville calme je tiens à le dire
nous avons très peu d'atteintes aux
biens très peu de dates at d'atteintes
aux personnes donc très peu de
cambriolages très peu d'agressions et
c'est donc des chiffres de délinquance
qui vont sont plutôt bons mais par
contre
les incivilités qui sont récurrentes
alors des petites choses là j'ai une
dame qui m'a il m'a contacté ce matin
parce que des gamins ont jeté une pierre
dans sa danse à vitré et donc elle à la
vitre cassée
voilà dire votre viseur casse pdd des
jeunes qui se mettent devant les
commerces et qui vont régulièrement la
porte pour arracher quelques mètres le
commerçant bon toutes ces petites choses
et on a une gendarmerie qui fait un
excellent travail et le résultat sur la
délinquance mais pas hot sur ces
incivilités on ne peut rien faire parce
que l'an général et les fauteurs sont
mineurs et vous disent sonné à la barre
e
nous ne pouvons rien faire contre eux
puisqu'ils sont mineurs alors voilà une
sont mineurs doux j'imagine la
convocation des parents que vous disent
les parents avant d'appliquer cette
mesure pourquoi les parents ne
réussissait pas à calmer leurs enfants
pleins il ya plusieurs types de parents
il y a les parents qui sont un petit peu
en abandon alors il ya une forte
corrélation entre cette entrée dans la
délinquance et puis l'abandon scolaire
on se rend compte en fait qu'on a des
gamins qui ont 14 ans qui court déjà une
plusieurs plusieurs incivilités comment
dire sur le dos et en fait on se rend
compte que ces gamins depuis l'âge de 12
ans ne sont plus scolarisés
alors ça c'est une corrélation qui est
indéniable on nous l'avons constaté
alors nous avons les parents qui sont un
petit peu en en échec d'éducation je
vais dire et ne disent pas écouté mort
j'en peux plus avec mon gamin j'ai tout
essayé pourtant on lui a donné une bonne
éducation mais on sait pas ce qui se
passe ça fait quelques années qu'il
qu'il déraille et qu'il qui le qu'il
commet tous ses méfaits
ensuite on allait ensuite on a les
familles qui sont carrément complices
qui qui se disent batch à mon gamin je
vais mettre dehors pour être tranquille
pour pouvoir faire la fête
et puis d'audenge et quand cette
application de leur supprimer les aides
facultatives social ça a marché vous
avez constaté des réels résultats
oui oui tout à fait comme vous êtes tout
à l'heure beaucoup de perturbateurs ont
disparu des radars
et donc il ya eu quand même un
électrochoc en je pense que le fait que
cette mesure soit médiatisé
ça a quand même fait en contre aux
parents sur les pensions rendu compte
qu'il était un peu trop loin et puis que
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens étaient
d'accord avec avec cette décision a
beaucoup lé une grande partie de la
population française était d'accord avec
cette décision et on est pas tout peu
après pas tout le monde est d'accord
avec cette mesure
non non il ya vraiment des gens qui qui
qui qui n'en ont rien à faire de
l'autorité ce soit la mienne celle de 7
des ministres de la gendarmerie du
président de la république sur des gens
qui sont complètement rebellés
aujourd'hui un rebelle qui n'en ont rien
à faire qui n'ont pas de pitié de toi de
repères et je pense qu'avec cela ça va
être très très compliqué enfin quand je
dis que certains sont pas d'accord
olivier ferrand par exemple ministre de
la santé s'est dit contre ce genre de
mesure qu'en pensez vous écouter s'il
monsieur vers on me donne des bonnes les
bonnes solutions et les appliquerait si
je me permets excusez moi mais c'est un
peu ce que les collègues maires qui ont
impliqué les mêmes mesures et moi-même
reprochons à notre gouvernement sait que
ont malheureusement nous nous sommes des
hommes de terrain nous vivons tous les
jours ces incivilités
nous nous essayons de faire le maximum
et malheureusement on manque au manque
dead et donc si le gouvernement peut
nous donner des aides ont les appliquera
avec grand plaisir
est-ce que c'est pas notre travail de
deux entrées principales de régler tout
ça puisque la sécurité reste une
prérogative de l'état merci beaucoup
frédéric bricout d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin en direct sur rt
france